enfin cabu cabu dessinateur insolent
avec les puissants et les grandes
gueules
on s'en rend compte qu'avec votre
dernier les interdits de cabu 250
dessins inédits présentés par jérôme
jérôme duhamel chez albin michel
évidemment on se dit des sens interdits
mais qui ose interdire des défunts qui a
vu sa part un invraisemblable c'est à
dire que moi je vais très bien le canard
enchaîné et uniquement des saints ils
ont pas envie parce que c'est un journal
de journalistes
mais le canard enchaîné teint est un
journal politique si ce qui fait que
certains aient ça ne passe pas parce que
il traite sociétés ou des demeures sont
mes et puis il est peut-être aussi vous
travaillez du calembour et antennes de
aussi d'un certain aussi ne peut pas
passer ça passe tellement vite que tout
passe mais qu'est-ce que cela parce que
là c'est vraiment un cas but très
méchant très cruel est ce qu'il ya un
seuil de tolérance pour employer un mot
à la mode qui ne faut pas dépasser
est-ce qu'on peut résumer le jeu vous
fait rire avec tout est compris avec la
scène pour désamorcer pour ne pas
dramatiser montrer le grotesque de
toutes les situations même message est
ce qui vous est arrivé de faire vider
simplement méchant et que vous allez
regretter ensuite en anglais je suis
quand même si ça fait rire c'est la
seule justification et l'origan alors
chacun trouvera peut-être des limites
d'antan en tant que lecteur mais moi je
ne mange plus rire avec tout je crois je
crois dans ce livre j'aime beaucoup me
comprends très bien qu'ils aient goûté
que ledit interview et un mini salle et
je trouve que je suis encore trop gentil
parce que avec tout ce qu'on nous
ingurgitons les jours avec tous
en ce monde dans lequel on vit dans
lequel je vis et je trouve que je suis
en dessous de ce que je devrais être
c'est un métier de provocation c'est sûr
de réflexion plus méchant ah oui je
trouve que je voulais pas assez ah oui
je pense et méchant ah non parce que
celui ci l'a vraiment on va voir
quelques dessins se sont prononcés tous
les dessins ne sont pas sont pas
méchants à l'inversé des dessins
d'autres se demandent pourquoi ils sont
interdits enfin servir hier l'otan dit
les hôtesses sont aussi vieilles et pour
les avions on voit bien que ça fera
plaisir à terre là les pendants monde un
gant
comment économique voilà alors si vous
mettez les au tesson ou six âgés que les
avions cela passerait peut-être vous
voyez tous mais ce qui fait ce qui fait
rire peut-être c'est pourri quoi aimer
oui mais c'est vrai que quand je fouille
à dessein bon on va pas loin c'est vous
montez l'abbé pierre alors vous qu'il
est compressé quand il est compressé on
dirait césar bon parcours mais c'est
vrai essayer si si si mais c'est parti a
comparé cruelle soit écouter ici on a
bien fait le test avec la renault la
hier soir le crash on pourrait essayer
avec l'abbé pierre nous ça nous a donné
des césar non bon évidemment il ya des
dessins contre la police contre tu peux
contre tous et ça va de soi je dirais
qu'on a mende quelques-uns et si vous
aider à passer le contre sur les eaux de
les hommes politiques est ce que vous
allez des limites par exemple quand on
parle du président quand vous faites des
sens au président de la république
non surtout pas surtout je crois qu'il
faut lui supporte très bien d'ailleurs
on n'a jamais d'ennui
nous les dessinateurs n'a jamais d'ennui
avec les hommes politiques c'est plutôt
c'est toujours les militaires les
religieux oui mais jamais les hommes
politiques au contraire il ya pas de
ceinture du nom sur le pape rappelle
plus je dois comprendre des dessins de
deux les interdits de cabu s'il vous
plaît dans lequel on voit là et alors ça
c'est des dessins rocard et mitterrand
c'est pas méchant ce nom c'est pas
méchant mais bon j'ai pris des saint
jean sur couesnon et tous vos dessins ne
sont pas cruel mais certains quand même
vous allez trouver cruel dit marc voyer
une chose qui m'intéresse quand même
c'est que les interdits rue ils sont pas
interdit par la censure
ils ont interdit par les rédacteurs en
chef de nouveau moi j'ai je suis allé
très souvent le témoigner pour toutes
les caractéristiques je sais que c'était
là bas parce que c'était un travail à
mi-temps pour kavanagh pour tous ces
gens-là et l'instant l'acceptaient le
truc qui poursuivait ce qui interdisait
aux femmes
maintenant c'est plus intéressant a
constaté ça c'est l'autre libre de cabu
mais j'ai reçu il ya deux jours
surviennent par l'acquisition cyrille
godefroy c'était du passé aux aveux
vous êtes confié jean-paul tiberi vous
raconter votre vie votre jeunesse au
premier dessin et puis bientôt nous vous
raconter à travers des dessins tout la
foulée les premiers dessins de cabu
et c'est vrai que j'ai eu plusieurs
procès l'antimilitarisme déclaré 6,6
procès ces procès avec l'armée j'en ai
eu un avec médecins et voyez il ya une
quinzaine d'années j'ai eus nous
raconter dans les familles une émission
de gan sinclair il était en face du
général bigeard
mais il avait fait des dessins qui n'ont
pas plu du tout non parce que il avait
raconté sa vie en cinq minutes
ça s'appelait l'invité du jeudi et il se
trouve qu'il était toujours du mauvais
côté et toujours du côté des perdants
il ya commencé la gamme 40 alors je les
jeux les faits poursuivis par les
allemands après il a fait l'un d'ogeu
les faits poursuivis par l'aîné viêt
après il a fait l'algérie je n'ai fait
poursuivi parlent les les effets la gare
et puis c'était au moment où ou bulles
am été vendus aux américains je crois
une histoire comme ça même
l'informatique français l'été c'était la
débâcle de l'informatique française je
le faisais courir devant une machine
électronique et là il s'est levé et bon
un sinclair lui dit écoutez il met du
poil à gratter
parce qu'il a aidé à réaliser que toute
sa vie il avait été invaincu mais vous
avez un beau compliment il est là bissau
vous êtes de irrécupérable mais je
pourrais m'en a oui oui parce que début
de l'émission 19 ans confié le mois qu'a
but en trois semaines grâce aux petits
gars et à la fin il m'a dit non je crois
que finalement je pourrais pas un jeu il
ya eu aussi roger peyrefitte roger
peyrefitte parce qu'il voulait pas
parler de la pédérastie militante
alors je les fais il parlait de
l'occupation et je les fais tendu et
j'ai émis j'étais tendu parce que j'ai
couché avec un allemands pendant la
guerre
et s'est levé il ya des non monsieur
jamais avec un allemand je sais pas si
on pouvait faire ça à 20 heures c'était
une émission qui passait le jeudi après
midi d'audience un élément on est
tranquille oreilles tout dépend du
contexte est ce que est ce que vous
pourriez accueillir cabillaud figaro je
ne sais pas si c'est plutôt un luxe
aurait posé la question mais évidemment
il ya des dessins extrêmement drôle de
cabu comment dans la cage de l'armée
trier pas dans la cage de la surtout à
côté du courrier des lecteurs je sais
pas si oui
trois cars 2 le tennis tu comment vous
précis porter sa voix s'est ainsi fait
faites le compte vous verrez on a laissé
passer une allure car un crados salaces
et on revient au zinc un bloc de cabu
c'est bien jean 6
et puis elle a joué comme au lycée le
drapeau blanc il y en a vraiment
commencé n'écrasez pas les drogués ça
crève les pneus
oui oui qu'on le voit pas ce qu il est
il a deux il est différent mais perdu
est ce qu est ce qu on sait vous êtes un
personnage méchant non parce que je me
défoule à la en fait que me permettent
dans la vie de normal quoi mais ce qui
est intéressant explique comment
travaillent les dessinateurs et on se
rend compte que la plupart d'entre eux
font beaucoup plus de dessins qui ne
publie aucun doute à fait différent du
métier de journaliste parce que mes
séjours est ce que vous écrivez un
article est publié en fait dessinateur
produits beaucoup plus qui nous pollue
et ça ça sent les chutes et c'est rare
que c'est la première fois qu'un
dessinateur nous en tout cas ma
connaissance publie c'est ce qu'on
appelle des chutes mais ces chutes de
dessin j'ai des chutes là vous voulez
que je vous avais bien nous les montrer
pendant toute l'émission ou frais des
déchets oui mais c'est vrai que vous
détestez beaucoup de jeu permettant ça
c'est dans le livre
autobiographique on voit qu'il ya des
personnes que vous aimez beaucoup vous
parler par exemple de traîner vous aimez
beaucoup il ya tati jacques tati parce
que l'image est connu que j'ai connus ou
inconnus vous aimez beaucoup tati c'est
pas évident sur organise interdit les
interviews vous pouvez raconter c'est
pas parce qu'ils vous aiment qu'on est à
l'apaisement entre gangs de sa vie elle
doit arrêter si vous avez bien connu
cette année sur ce plateau du seuil la
loi écrit à lait concentré c'est ça qui
s'appelait comment qui s'appelait
l'adulent théologie il a commencé sous
un pseudonyme parce qu'il ose et papiers
après la sortie en aide à l'italie veut
entrer en vigueur pour le texte et c'est
vous qui l'illustré mais le
caricaturiste que vous êtes
c'est vrai qu'on se connaît très bien
les personnages ou les ans les 10 et
c'est mémé mais d'être irem des gens
communs que sont des favoris à vous je
vois anne sinclair par exemple six ans
qu'elle qu'on puisse le faire vous
l'embellie s'est encore vraiment là vous
vous trouvez ça trouve très gai mais là
on est encore plus belle
c'est vraiment vous et moi mais c'est ça
on a tous les droits des décès n'était
enfin quand ces prêts voilà c'est ça il
faut faire des bouquins c'est aussi un
endroit sûr et enfin quand on dirige un
journal vous avez droit de faire un
choix c'est un choix
mais elle ne mettait pas de côté
toujours les mêmes thèmes je te dire la
mort en larmes et la religion voyez est
ce que vous allez vous rendre dans ces
défunts il ya une pratique pense pas
qu'aucun j'aurais unis publiés d'aucuns
voudraient bien parce que si j'avais eu
une bonne critique du figaro je me
serais dit merde je me suis planté
j'ai répondu